next to the presentations to outstanding
motion picture writers of course I'm not
too familiar with him because I had
lived most of my stuff pretty I never
and I never read what's wrong with a
teleprompter
these awards will be made by Miss Claire
Trevor in Hollywood mr. Karl Malden a
New York and Miss Audrey Hepburn in
London
incidentally miss Hepburn's dressing
room at Paramount is right behind mine
in fact that's how Alfred Hitchcock got
the idea for rear window
in our ladies and gentlemen Hollywood
and miss Claire Trevor
why did your wonderful actor thank you
now for the best motion picture story
the winner is
broken land Philip Yordan
I could play the New York mr. Carl
Bowden
Thank You bobland good evening and now
for the best story and screenplay hmm on
the waterfront punch uber
well thank you very much and because my
old man PP Schulberg
was a screenwriter back in 1912 and
wrote something called the Eagles Nest
for DW Griffith and because a picture he
made called wings I think I think when
the first Academy Award for the best
production this little fella gives me an
attic tick tonight and thank you very
much
thank you Karl Malden this is a
desperate hour now from London reading
the names of all the nominees as we used
to do miss Audrey Hepburn
for Best Screenplay regardless of
whether developed from published
material or unpublished story by some
other writer or writers the following
writers have been nominated Stanley
Roberts the Caine Mutiny Stanley Kramer
productions Columbia Gorge Seaton the
country girl pearlberg Steven
Productions paramount John Michael Hayes
rear-window
they can incorporated paramount Billy
Wilder Samuel Taylor and Ernest Lehman
Sabrina paramount Albert Hackett Francis
Goodridge and Dorothy Kingsley Seven
Brides for Seven Brothers MGM and the
winner is the country girl George sleep
we haven't got time I'm not supposed to
say thanks I merely want to express my
gratitude to everybody who helped thank
you wonderful job George